bonjour à tous aujourd'hui dans science
clic
l'imposante heures entre la bille de
plomb et la plume
lequel de ces deux objets ton style le
plus vite on serait tenté de répondre
que c'est la bille de plomb car c'est
l'objet le plus massif des deux est en
effet si on les lâche à la surface de la
terre
c'est bien la bille de plomb qui va
toucher le sol avant la plume
cependant si on réalise la même
expérience à la surface de la lune
c'est à dire dans le vide de l'espace on
observe que la plume et la bille de
plomb atteignent le sol exactement au
même moment en réalité lorsqu'on
effectue l'expérience sur terre la plume
ne tombe pas plus lentement parce
qu'elle est plus légère mais parce qu'en
tombant et présente une grande surface
d'appui et ainsi elle frotte et se
heurtent davantage contre les molécules
d'air qui composent l'atmosphère s'il
était possible de retirer l'atmosphère
alors on observerait que comme sur la
lune les deux objets tombent exactement
de la même façon
[Musique]
ceci est vrai quelles que soient les
objets auxquels on s'intéresse s'il ne
ressentent que la gravité c'est à dire
qu'ils sont en chute libre
tous les objets tombent exactement de la
même façon
[Musique]
imaginons maintenant un être humain en
train de tomber sans être ralenti par
les frottement de l'atmosphère ce il
lâche une pomme devant lui comme tous
les corps tombe de la même façon
l'humain et la pomme vont suivre
exactement la même trajectoire
ainsi de son point de vue la pomme
semble flotter devant ses yeux
[Musique]
de plus s'il essaye maintenant de la
pesée avec une balance au moment où il
la place sur le plateau la pomme ne peut
pas prendre appui sur la balance car
celle ci tombe en même temps la balance
ne ressens donc aucune force et elle
indique que le poids de la pomme a
disparu en réalité la pomme est encore
bel et bien soumis à son poids c'est
d'ailleurs lui qu'il entraîne dans sa
chute mais comme l'humain la balance
tombe en même temps il ne bouge pas les
uns par rapport aux autres
c'est cette situation dans laquelle le
poids des objets semblent disparaître
qu'on appelle un pesanteur ou plus
communément appelée en heure dans notre
quotidien
les situation d'impesanteur sont très
rares sur terre on la ressent par
exemple si l'on se trouve dans une cage
d'ascenseur en train de tomber pour
éviter d'avoir à tomber dans une cage
d'ascenseur
il existe également des avions
spécialisés dont le seul but est de
s'affranchir de la gravité pour ce faire
l'avion va suivre la même trajectoire
qu'ils auraient pu s'ils étaient en
chute libre
de cette façon dès le moment où il
s'aligne avec cette trajectoire
tous les objets les passagers à
l'intérieur de l'avion se trouve en
impesanteur en impesanteur toutes les
directions sont équivalentes
il n'y a plus la gravité pour faire la
distinction entre le haut et le bas les
liquides former des gouttes parfaitement
ronde qui semble flotter et les objets
en combustion donne lieu à des flammes
sphérique
contrairement aux flammes verticale que
l'on connaît dont la forme étaient
étirées par la gravité
malheureusement sur terre le phénomène
d'impesanteur n'est jamais parfait cela
est dû principalement aux frottements
avec l'air qui ralentissent et des
villes des objets lorsqu'ils tombent
afin d'éviter ces frottements
il est donc nécessaire de sortir de
l'atmosphère et de se placer dans le
vide de l'espace
c'est le rôle que l'on a donné à la
station spatiale internationale en
orbite autour de la terre
la station spatiale est constamment en
chute libre en train de tomber
mais grâce à sa vitesse très importante
elle parvient à suivre la courbure
terrestre de sorte à ne jamais se
rapprocher du sol comme elle est en
chute libre à l'intérieur de la station
les objets les astronautes semble
flotter car ils sont en situation
d'impesanteur ce laboratoire spatial
permettent ainsi des expériences
scientifiques complexes nécessitant de
s'affranchir de la gravité ce qui serait
impossible à reproduire sur terre
[Musique]